I just vibe-coded an entire app in two hours.
It works. It looks great, but I have no idea if it's actually secure.
Like, could someone hack this thing?
Oh, they absolutely could. And they will.
Unless you use these five prompts to lock it down before it's too late.
Prom number one.
Tell your AI to implement rate limiting on all endpoints.
Five attempts max per 15 minutes on login routes.
That way hackers can't brute force their way in.
Oh yeah, that's smart.
What about the passwords I left in the code?
You did what?
That's prompt number two, you buffoon.
Tell the AI to scan your entire code base for any hard code.
And prompt three.
Move all sensitive data to environment variables.
Make sure nothing is exposed in the front end or committed to get.
You absolute walnut.
Okay, okay, I'm writing this down.
What else?
Promt four.
Scented eyes all user inputs and reject anything oversized or malformed.
Unless you want someone injecting code straight into your database.
That sounds bad.
It is bad, Peter.
And finally, prompt five.
Run a full security audit and report any remaining vulnerabilities.
Think of it as a final health check before you unleash your little creation on the world.
Bang, Struy, you just saved my app and probably my identity.
You're welcome.
Now, if you found this useful, follow this page for more tips.
So you don't get destroyed on the internet.
Do it now.